I wrote this book in just 87 days. And I
did it with no editor, no AI, no
publishing deal, no agent, no writing
degree. Not only that, I did it in a
Google doc while having a full-time job,
being a husband, and taking care of my
three kids. Since then, I've written my
second book, which will publish later
this year, and I'm already working on my
third book. And in this video, I'm going
to expose why less than 1% of people who
say they want to write a book actually
write a book. and the ridiculously
stupid simple system that you can steal
to finally write the freaking book
you've been sitting on. But before we
get into all of that, I need to walk you
through why I'm so bullish on writing a
book, especially this year. Before I
wrote my book, I saw a trend happening
in the culture that scared the living
daylights out of me. I was thinking
about writing my book and I had people
from all kinds of directions who were
telling me, "No, no, don't write that
book. Instead of writing a book that you
sell for $9, man, turn it into a digital
course that you sell for $99. And at the
same time, I was seeing indie bookshops
closing because nobody was reading books
anymore. Instead, they were scrolling
TikTok and Only Fans for 4 hours a day.
And then to top it all off, we have AI,
which has made all information so
readily accessible that people were
like, why the heck would I read books
when I can just prompt chat GPT, tell me
how to do this, and then it gives you
the information. Why would you read a
book? Well, here's why. Dr. James Hovart
who's a neurologist and ex-teer did a
study on over 80 countries. Okay, this
is not just America. This is not just
the UK. This is 80 total countries. And
in that study, he found that the Gen Z
generation was the first generation in
over 200 years to not surpass the prior
generation on any cognitive abilities.
The prior generation to Gen Z is the
millennials. I am a millennial. I'm a
33year-old man. And every generation
stopping at the millennials prior to
this has surpassed the prior generation
in all cognitive abilities except Gen Z.
This is everything from basic attention
to memory to literacy to numeracy to
executive functioning all the way down
to just general IQ. Gen Z score lower on
every single scale against millennials.
And the only correlating factor that
could have changed those results so
dramatic was that Jenzi has an increase
in lowquality digital technology. Again,
Tik Tok, the scrolling, the internet,
all that bull crap. And a significant
decrease in reading physical books and
writing their ideas down. Increase in
digital technology, decrease in reading
books and writing ideas down. All of
that led to what is quite possibly the
stupidest generation that we've had so
far. This should scare the living
daylights out of you because at the same
time you got a bunch of people on
Twitter who are like reading is a waste
of time and take action and take action
and take action. But our ancestors have
been writing stuff down since the days
of Jesus and they would spend 3 to four
hours reading every single day to become
the smartest people living alive. That's
why we still read Jesus. It's why we
still read Aristotle. It's why we still
read Marcus Aurelius. It's why we still
read Gary Benga, Gary Halpert. these
guys who are readers and writers, which
is what leads me to this video. Because
not only do I believe that writing your
own book can solve 99% of these problems
for you, but also can throw you into a
new universe in your own business by
writing your book. Yes, this will grow
your personal brand and give you more
autonomy in your life to sell your own
stuff. I'm going to tell you how we're
going to do it for many, many reasons
that I definitely want to get into and
then I'll give you the practical
step-by-step so stupid simple process
that you're going to walk away being
able to write your book in less than 3
months just like I did. The first thing
is that the best writers are voracious
readers. Austin Cleon talks about like
books are made of books which just means
to write one book I've read a hundred
books and so when you're writing a book
you are naturally reading other books
which gives you an immense injection of
higher quality content than the stuff
that you would scroll on Twitter or
email newsletters or god forbid Tik Tok
and only fans and what that ends up
doing is the process of reading all
those books to try and write your book
gives you more wisdom and agency in your
own life beyond just writing the book
itself. It's actually training you as a
person who can take an idea, solve a
problem and be a selfidactic learner.
Meaning you are creating the
entrepreneur within yourself to continue
building businesses. Right? Readers and
writers are people that are trying to
solve a problem. You do the research to
solve that problem. You execute the
research by writing down the ways to
solve that problem. Which means you are
doing the same process parallel as an
entrepreneur. So, you're creating these
habits within yourself to be a better
solopreneur like I am. I am now a
full-time solarreneur since publishing
my book. I had a full-time career. Now,
I am my own full-time career. I sell my
own stuff on my own time full-time. And
I truly believe that writing this book
was the launching pad into that world
because it taught me so much about
solarpreneurship. Another benefit is
that there are no ads or AI in books,
especially prior to 2022, right? I'm
sure people use Chat GPT and crap like
that to write in books nowadays, but
those are trash. Nobody reads those. I
guarantee you're not getting recommended
those because they're absolute dog crap.
But the ability to actually pick up a
long- form book that isn't littered with
a stupid, you know, protein shake ad
every pages like your Twitter feed is,
like your email newsletter is, you can
actually sit there and increase your
concentration, increase your ability to
single task while consuming the highest
quality content possible on this earth.
A long- form book with no ads and no AI
in it is going to change the way that
your mind thinks and it's going to
absorb high wisdom at a higher
efficiency rate than if you were just
reading Twitter and newsletters and all
that bull crap littered with ads,
littered with crap AI copy because all
you're going to do is regurgitate the
crap that you consume, right? You are
what you eat. And if you eat bull crap
all day long as opposed to actually
reading physical books and understanding
the greatest wisdom possibilities at the
highest level, then you are simply going
to regurgitate the crap that you consume
as opposed to enjoying this stuff.
Thirdly, nothing has more legacy than a
book. Those guys who were touting to me
to create a $99 course, a $299 course,
I've done all those things, okay? I've
created $1,000 courses that have sold
multi6 figures. I've created $500
courses, $299 courses, $99 courses. I've
created all those things and I will
continue to create courses. But that
does not actually take away from the
ability to write a book. A book has
significantly more legacy. Like this
book, I wrote this book in 2022,
launched in 2023, and it sells more
copies today than it did then. Courses
have peaks and troughs, right? When you
launch a course, you sell a bunch of
courses and then the course gets kind of
old. People get fatigued with courses.
Not only that, but courses actually just
sit on people's hard drives or sit on
people's login and they don't
necessarily consume them. And so the
legacy of that course dies very, very
quickly. It is an asset that you could
sell over and over, but it gets fatigued
so much faster than a book. Not only
that, when somebody orders my book, it's
going to sit on their bookshelf. You see
all these books behind me and it is a
physical reminder of me and my domain
and my expertise and getting into my
world. They'll read this book and it has
a higher level of authority into it
which I'll dive more into that. But this
is a physical representation of me in
their home far beyond a course. A course
never does that. A course is on their
digital drive. They look at it once.
They watch the first three videos.
They're like, "Ah, it's pretty cool."
And then they forget about it entirely.
You do make a good injection of cash at
the beginning, but it doesn't have the
long tail, the longevity, the growth
that a book actually does. And so, this
book is going to sell for 20, 30, 40
years, where that course is dead within
12 months. It's the same reason why
books like this, the Bible, which were
written over 2,000 years ago, this is
the form of choice that Jesus wanted his
disciples to carry on the legacy of
Christianity in written form. or other
books from Marcus Aurelius's meditation,
Steven Presfield's books, all of his
content from the 70s, the 80s, the 90s,
everything like that carries such a high
legacy. Coffee break I'm talk but I'm
spitting wisdom, bro. Bro, I'm spitting
wisdom. Speaking of Steven Presfield,
the next benefit is truly the
progression of your life being
documented. When you see all of Steven
Presfield's books or like one of my
favorite authors, John Mark Comr. John
Mark Comr has written a book in the
progression of his life. The first book
he wrote was about depression. The next
book that he wrote was about eliminating
hurry from his life. And then he wrote a
book about love and marriage. And then
he wrote a book about rejecting the lies
of the devil in his life. And so on and
so on. And as he's learning these things
in life, he's like documenting these.
And these will be passed down to his
kids. You can have the same impact in
writing a book that lasts significantly
longer. So, if you're like me, I'm
building an autonomous business where I
am self-employed and I'm not chasing
clients and I'm not doing anything other
than building a leverage-based lifestyle
where I can wake up, write 3, four hours
a day, make a multi6figure income doing
that sort of thing and then move on with
my day, read books, enjoy life, go to
the pool, hang out with my family. to do
that sort of thing. It takes so much
learning and skill stacking that along
the way I'm documenting everything I'm
learning from copywriting to funnels to
social media to mindset to actually
building the habits to the content
systems. There's so much. And when I'm
documenting those, I am packaging them
not only in emails and YouTube videos
and courses and all that, but I'm taking
my best of the best of the best ideas
out of all those things and packaging
them into books in the most timeless way
possible so that I can pass them out in
the most legacy driven way possible. And
you could see my progression of life
towards a fully autonomous, fully free,
fully abundantfilled life where I am
happy and achieved my goals. Every step
is the step that you can take and write
a book. So that way your last chapter
can be passed on to the next generation,
your kids, your friends or whoever comes
after you. Books are a progression of
your journey. Which leads to two more
benefits. The next one is that actually
writing a book is self-discovery and
self-mastery. When you write a book,
you're not writing a book because you
are a master at that idea. You are
writing the book to become a master at
that idea. Because to write that book,
you have to explore the ideas that
you've already learned and go beyond
them. You have to dig the well deeper
into every single idea. When I was
writing meaningful marketing, which by
the way, you can grab this book
completely free. There's a link in the
description below. You can click that
link, put in your email, and I'll
actually send you a free Kindle PDF
version of this book. It is a number one
bestseller on Amazon, has only five star
reviews. I truly believe that this will
help you build marketing mindsets and
systems to help you grow in a not sleazy
way. I think you're going to love it.
But in writing this book, I learned so
much about myself. I had to challenge my
own ideas, my own thoughts. I had to
simplify the way that I was thinking
about those ideas so that I can
communicate them clearly. And that
process, like Seth Goden calls it,
thrashing. But that process of thrashing
in my mind forced me to discover things
about myself and my skill set and this
topic in general that I had never
discovered before. I went down the
rabbit hole to find incredible stories
and simplified systems and ways of
writing and ways of communicating. And I
boiled everything down into this book
while I was learning it. And I learned
so much about myself and so much about
the idea of marketing that I didn't even
think about when I first started writing
the book. And then when you publish this
book, you get the final and the last
benefit of writing your own book. And
that is you become an authority on that
topic. I mean, think about it. What's
going to give you more authority? Hey, I
launched a $99 course on this topic or
hey, I wrote a book about it. Writing a
book obviously gives you more stature,
more respect, especially amongst high
status people. People who read are high
status. Readers are leaders. That's not
an opinion. That's just fact. If you are
not reading, chances are you have a
lowquality IQ. It just is what it is.
Okay. Everybody who's in a high status
ecosystem, I was the vice president of a
marketing company and I was in rooms
with seven figure business owners, eight
figure business owners. While I was the
vice president, I could tell you every
single highquality person in that room
was reading books and writing their own
ideas down. It was almost assumed that's
what you were doing. And so when you can
walk in and say, "I wrote a book on X
topic." that is going to give you far
more status and respect than saying I
created a course. Everybody can create a
course there. It's almost it's almost
like assume that even if you did create
a course, it's a crappy course and
you're stealing people's money and it's
it's almost this bad taste in people's
mouth. Now, there are a lot of great
course creators out there, but to write
a book, to have the discipline, to have
the structure, the knowledge, the wisdom
to actually write a book is going to
command respect from your customers,
from high-paying clients. It will grow
your business. It is in parallel with
the way that my business grew when I
wrote meaningful marketing. I do believe
that even just the ability to write that
I was a published author in my Twitter
bio actually increased the conversion
rate of people when I tweeted and I
wrote long form essays and things like
that on Twitter and they clicked over to
my profile and they saw that I was a
published author and I just happen to be
really good at marketing. Hence, I wrote
the book on marketing. So, I actually
was able to launch this as a number one
bestseller. So, in my Twitter bio, I put
number one best-selling author. That is
status. That status is attractive.
Attraction equals magnetic to money. And
even if you're not writing to sell your
book and you just want to write the
book, you will attract more highquality
people. You will attract more dollars
into your business, especially if the
topic that you write about is congruent
with your business model. I wrote a book
about marketing. I have a marketing
business. And so what ends up happening
is you become a master of that topic.
You attract more authority. It it
propels your personal brand online,
which means you can use this book to
attract more people online and get them
to your email list. This is exactly how
I did it. Okay? I wrote a book and
exactly how I told you earlier. I said
you can go get this book for free or you
can buy it on Amazon. No problem. You
can support me that way. But you could
get this book for free in exchange for
your email address. And guess what's
going to happen? You're going to join my
email list and I'm going to email you
every single day a fantastic marketing
story and tips and guess what? I'm going
to sell you something else. That's how
it works. And you're going to love it
because the thing that I sell you is
going to be so helpful, so impactful to
your life that you'll say, "Absolutely.
I would love to buy that." And that
grows your business because it allows
you to attract people outside of your
nineto-ive job, outside of your clients.
You become an authority in your world.
And as an authority, your personal brand
grows, your email list grows, which
gives you a big lever to sell your own
stuff, which gives you the opportunity
to fire your boss, fire your clients,
and step towards a fully autonomous
lifestyle where you can continue
attracting high-quality people into your
world. Those people become customers.
You serve them with excellence. You
deliver products that solve big
problems. And eventually you start
making the kind of money that you want
to make that you've always desired to
make that you've never had the
opportunity to make because you've been
working under someone else's labor.
Someone has been outsourcing your labor,
your time for a fraction of the cost of
what they're making so they can make a
profit off you. But you launching your
own book is a launchpad into a world
where you make your own stuff. You sell
your own stuff. You're building your own
world. You're building your own business
where you can step into a world where
you report to no one but you. And now
that I've hyped you up, I want to walk
you through the exact stepbystep process
for you to go from a blank page to a
fully written book in less than 90 days
with this stupid simple system. All
right, the first step to writing your
own book is you need to pick a big idea.
You don't have to write a title, a
subtitle. You don't have to outline the
book. You don't have to do any of that.
You just have to pick a big idea. And
the way that I like to pick my ideas is
I use two P's that I balance between is
what is a problem that I can solve and
what am I passionate about writing.
Okay, so when you're passionate about
something, you typically have enough
information and fodder and juice to
actually have a book's worth of
information. That's what a lot of people
run into this and they're like, I don't
have a book's worth of ideas in my head.
I guarantee you do. I'm about to show
you in just a second. If you are
passionate about an idea, chances are
you have already naturally done the
research that it takes to write that
book or you are naturally wanting to do
the research as you are writing the
book. Either way is fine because you're
going to have a lot of fun doing it
because you're passionate about it. And
then on the flip side, your passion
should solve a problem. If you haven't
caught it already, we're obviously
talking about non-fiction books. I
cannot help you write a fiction book. I
love fiction novels, but I don't know
anything about writing those things. So,
I'm going to walk you through my exact
process. Okay? Let's say I'm writing a
fourth book. Okay? And my fourth book is
going to be called, let's let's say it's
called Hit Publish Daily. Okay, Hit
Publish Daily is going to be a book
about building daily writing habits
because that is a problem that solved a
major thing in my life, right? Learning
to write every day, helped me get my
ideas out on paper. It helped me write
my daily emails, which sold my club on
my school community. By the way, I'll
leave a link to my school community down
below. It is filled with writers and
copywriters who want to fire their boss
and move towards a fully autonomous
lifestyle selling their own stuff. I
have an entire community built around
this idea. If that resonates with you,
feel free to click the link down below
to check it out. So, let's say I'm
writing the book Hit Publish Daily. The
problem that I'm solving is I'm helping
people build a daily writing habit. If
they can build a daily writing habit,
they will solve a ton of problems. Okay?
So, pick something that you're
passionate about solves a problem.
Building a daily writing habit solves a
problem. I'm passionate about the topic.
Okay, you can get four or five ideas
like this. Another one would be like, I
I would want to write a book about how
to break 100 in golf. I'm passionate
about golf. I love doing it. Solves a
problem for a bunch of beginners who
have never broken 100 in golf. I could
do this all day long. I can write a book
about self-development. I could write a
book about writing books. I could write
a book about copywriting. I got all
kinds of books in my head. You can, and
you do, too. You have tons of books in
your head. So you can write four or five
topics and you got to think which one
solves the biggest problem and has the
most passion. If you were going to heir
on one side, I would heir on a book that
you're passionate to write because the
more passionate you are to write the
book, the more likely you'll actually
write the book. So even if your f first
book isn't like a big super helpful
problem solving, it's going to give you
the launching pad to write a second
book, to write a third book, to write a
fourth book, and eventually you'll write
a really great book. But obviously your
first book, let's get your first book
out there into the world and show you
that hey I can write a book. So we have
passion, we have problem. Now you take
that topic, okay, on your piece of paper
and I want you to write down I want you
to just brain dump, okay? Just brain
dump little bullets of every tiny idea
attached to that topic. So, if I were
writing a book called Hit Publish Daily
and and I'm going to help you build a
daily writing habit, I might just jot
down whatever ideas that I have. I may
talk about like permissionless writing,
right? Where you don't need anyone's
permission to actually write every
single day. I may talk about sacred
hours, which are the hours in your day
which uh which you are the most
productive and least distracted. You
know, for me, it's like 5:15 in the
morning. I wake up, my kids are still
asleep, I don't have any obligations, my
phone's not going off, all that kind of
stuff. So, sacred hours might be one.
Uh, I may write a chapter about my pet
method, which is place, experience,
time, right? If you set a place, you
create an experience around it, and you
have a specific time, then you will
continue to write. I may uh write a
chapter about identity, having the
identity of a writer. If you have the
identity of a writer, well, what do
writers do? They write. And so on and so
on and so on and so on. Whatever comes
out of your head. Same thing with the
golf thing. If I were to write a book
about how to break 100, I may talk about
the importance of putting more, the
importance of driving. I may talk about
the mindset. I may talk about grip. I
may talk about all kinds of other random
things that helped me break 100 in golf.
The goal for you is to do this. I don't
want you to prompt Claude. I don't want
you to stroke chat GPT. I don't want you
to get on Twitter and do some re stop
it. Use your brain. Okay? It's not hard.
It's been around for thousands of years.
It's more advanced than Claude Diddley.
It's more advanced than than Chad GPT.
Whatever. Okay? Don't use that crap. Sit
there for a second. Grab a piece of
paper and think. Your goal is to get 20,
30, 40, 50 ideas. Just keep going. Set a
timer for 30 minutes. 15 minutes. You're
writing a book. You can't sit down for
15 minutes. Come on. Absolutely you can.
Okay? You sit down and you try and get
20, 30, 40 ideas on here. You just keep
going and keep going and keep going and
eventually you have chapters. You have
all of these tiny little chapters in
your book. Okay? You have basically
outlined a whole bunch of stuff that you
can write about. And then the next thing
that I want you to do is I want you to
take your piece of paper with all your
tiny little micro topic ideas and then I
want you to open up a Google doc. All
right? And in that Google doc, you could
create a new tab for each individual
micro idea that you have. Okay? So you
got your big topic and then you have
your 30, 40, 50 micro ideas. Now what
you have is you have a tab for every
blog you're going to write. You're not
going to write a chapter. We're not
writing a book. We are now writing blogs
because you know how much easier it is
to write a blog, a 500word,
thousandword, 1500word blog. It's so
much simpler and it's way less
overwhelming than saying, "I'm going to
write a chapter in my new book cuz then
with chapter comes all these
connotations. It has to be perfectly
structured and it's got to be 3,000
words and it has to have subtopics and
all this." No, no, no, no. You don't got
to do any of that. Okay? You got to sit
down and let's say I were to write a
chapter on permissionless writing. Okay?
Permissionless writing would be a
chapter in my book. It's really a blog.
I need to write a 500 to,000word blog,
which is so easy by the It would take
you 30 minutes to write, especially if
you have the passion for it. If I wanted
to write a blog about permissionless
writing, I'm going to use this exact
structure. Okay, the structure that I'm
going to use to write my blog is called
the SL structure. And what it stands for
is story lesson. If you've read some of
the bestelling non-fiction books in the
last 5 years, you'll see this structure
all over the place. It's a fantastic
structure. Atomic Habits uses it, The
Psychology of Money uses it, Seth Goden
uses it in all of his books. It's the
most simplest structure that you could
follow. The idea is that you would start
your chapter with a story because
stories hook readers. Readers are way
more addicted to stories, which is why
80% of book sales are fiction novels,
not non-fiction, is because most
non-fiction books are really dry and
boring and informational and nobody
wants to read that crap. But if you can
inject a story at the beginning of each
of your blog posts, then you can hook
the reader into the next chapter and get
them to extract the lesson at the end of
the story. So for permissionless
writing, I may tell a story about how
about 5 six years ago, I was working at
one of the largest churches in America.
I was the director of marketing. I was
working 50 to 60 hours a week. And every
bit of my energy was injected into that
job, injected into that career. And I
didn't do anything for myself.
Everything had to be approved through my
through my CMO, through our board of
director, all of this stuff. We had a
huge team that had to look at everything
and approve everything. And they ripped
all of my content apart. They ripped
everything I created apart. And so
everything I could publish had to go
through their permission. That's a
story. And then I'm going to give you
the lesson that writing is
permissionless. You can write anytime,
any part of the day, and nobody can tell
you not to do it. They don't have to
tell you what to write. None of that
crap. It is permissionless. So now I've
told you a story and you have extracted
the lesson out of that story. And that
one zinger is going to connect with
someone. You don't need to give them 80
lessons per chapter. In fact, you're
actually going to hurt your credibility
and hurt your ability to write the book
and hurt your authority if you try and
do that. Instead, you want to give one
good story and one good lesson from that
story so that your reader can remember
the story and extract the lesson later
in life. Now, you have a topic to write
about, 40, 50 different blog posts for
you to write, the structure for you to
write those blog posts, and now all you
need is the place, experience, and time
to actually write it. My pet method that
I talked about a little earlier, steal
it for yourself. Find a place that you
would enjoy writing in. create an
experience around it and set a time. For
example, I like to write in my office.
It's very peaceful. I hate coffee shops.
I hate how loud they are. I hate how
distracting they are. I hate it. I don't
like it. Okay? I like peace. Dead quiet.
I don't even listen to music when I
write half the time. I am zoned in. That
is the place I like to write. My office
experience I like to create is I like to
have a cup of espresso while I'm
writing. I sometimes like to have a
candle and some lowfi beats going, but
mostly just a candle. And that's the
experience I like to create. It's very
huga, very chill. And that's enjoyable
because when I come and sit down and
write, I'm chilling. I'm relaxing. I'm
having a great time. It's a wonderful
time. And then I set it up at about
5:15, 5:30 in the morning. My kids are
asleep. I'm not getting text messages.
The world isn't around me. I could just
write for 30, 45 minutes, maybe an hour
if I want to. If you do this for 2
months, you will have written a book.
Because how many chapters do you have?
40, 50, 60 chapters of those little blog
posts that you need to write. Well, it's
going to take you 30, 45 minutes to
write the blog. Okay? And so, you do
that once a day for two months. You
don't have to do it forever. You could
do it for 2 months. You wake up and you
actually write the blog once a day for
two months and bada bing, bada boom, you
have a book. Biggest caveat here is that
you do not need to edit this book,
structure this book, rewrite the chat.
You don't need to do any of that crap
until you write the first draft of this
book. So, you need to write every single
blog post first because if you write the
entire Google doc worth of blog posts
first, then you are 88% more likely to
actually finish the book. People who
finish the first draft are 88% more
likely to finish the entire book.
Meaning, you'll go back, you can edit
it, you can structure it in whatever
order actually makes sense, where you're
like, "Oh, I'm going to teach this
before I teach this." There's not even
magic to that. It's just you being smart
and realizing, "Oh, here is a good order
for me to put this book." And you could
just drag the tabs on Google. This
chapter first, this chapter first, this
chapter second. Like, you could just
order the book in Google. You don't need
Scrivener. You don't need Notion. You
don't need Obsidian. You don't need to
stroke Claw all day long. You need to
freaking write. And then after you
finish your first draft, you can edit
the book yourself. Please do not use AI
to edit the book. It will remove the
juice, the sauce out of your voice. It
will try and rewrite your voice
naturally by correcting it and all that
crap. Do not do that. Okay? Don't use
Grammarly. Don't use any of that stuff.
If anything, you're more than welcome to
send it off to an editor. Edit edit it
yourself or use Grammarly at the lowest
lowest lowest setting so it just
underlines if you misspelled a word or
something like that. But do not let it
change words. You edit it, you structure
it, you give it a title. 99% of your
book is done. Now, there's another world
in actually like getting the book
designed and structuring it and
publishing it on Kindle and launching it
as a number one bestseller. If you are
interested in me making that video to
show you how to do that, leave a comment
down below and tell me, I'm interested
in you telling me how to publish my book
and launch it as a number one
bestseller. I could teach you that. I
could walk you through it, but only if
that's what you want. But for today, you
have everything you need to write your
first book. Everything you need, and you
have every reason to do it. I hope this
video was helpful for you. And if it
was, do me a big big favor. Like the
video so the algorithm knows that I
served you well and that this content is
worth sharing on YouTube. And then
subscribe to my channel. It tells me
that you want me to create more
valuable, entertaining content like this
for you to continue to grow your
business, grow your life, and move
towards a fully autonomous work from my
damn self solopreneur being a writer.
How cool is that? Whether you're a
copywriter, an entrepreneur, a writer,
we're here to build a life that we want
to enjoy where we wake up every single
day, loving what we do, making money
from what we do, and enjoying the rest
of the day to just be humans. If you
like the sound of that, again, like the
video, subscribe to the channel, and I
will create more content on writing,
copywriting, funnels, solarreneurship,
anything you need to become fully
autonomous. Don't forget, meaningful
marketing is a link in the description
below. You can grab it for free. You can
buy it on Amazon if you want to support
me that way, but genuinely you can go
grab it for free. Put your email in,
tell me where to send it. I will get it
to you ASAP. You can enjoy it, print it,
download it, add it to your Kindle,
whatever you want. I appreciate your
support. Thank you again so much. And I
will catch you on the next one.
>> I spit juice.
>> That was good. That was good. Oo, I
don't know anybody that's giving the
sauce like I'm giving the sauce right
here on this channel. Obviously, this
book is amazing. Okay. I also have a
book about watches. I'm a big watch
enthusiast. I love herology. Look at
this, man. Look at this Rolex Daytona.
Absolutely stunningly beautiful. Do you
like watches? You can leave a comment
down below if you enjoy watches. I am a
big watch fan. I like You know why I'm a
watch fan? Cuz I value my time. Woo.